[Music]
it feels like this previously on was got
together by someone who's never watched
the show we have debbie matt at omni man
omni man matt at the house cecil looking
for mark amber mad at mark ooh eve's
here rudy's new body cecil mad at omni
man debbie looking for mark the immortal
looking for omni man and finishing with
mark looking as confused as we are after
that barrage of clips most of which are
about as orienting as a big arrow saying
you are here on a slightly bloody but an
otherwise blank sheet of paper the
immortal survives this which i know is
rather redundant but i only highlight it
because he really should be called the
humpty dumpty as in he only seems to be
immortal after somebody bothers to put
him back together again mark we need to
talk roll the previous episodes
commercials
someone's controlling you it's me mark
it's just me believing someone that you
think is being mind controlled when they
tell you this it's time for you to know
where i really come from and roll this
week's commercials my goodness we're
just a hop skip and they would be
invincible at tv sends away from a full
deck and we haven't even hit the title
card yet i am from viltrum but it's not
the planet i've told you about looks
like today's conductor on the exposition
train will be nolan grayson the next
stop is the planet philtrum we have
created a perfect civilization i'd say
the compulsory white leotards tell a
different story the perfect civilization
would have more than one fashion
designer in order for our people to
reach their full potential we had to
remove the weak
from our society wouldn't an advanced
species know that physical prowess is
just one facet while measuring the
overall strength of a society what about
the architects who dream the buildings
into existence the philosophers who
ponder the meaning of life through their
tales or the scientists who holy sh did
you see that person get cut in half that
was awesome when it was over our
population was cut in half but what
emerged from the ashes was unstoppable
since most of the battling we see on
screen looks like a bunch of people
taking cheap shots at each other when
they're not looking it seems like being
weak just means you don't have a spidey
sense problem is we have no idea how the
so-called process of random
assassination would ever stop wouldn't
it keep going until there's just one
highlander left we needed a better more
efficient way to conquer worlds i mean
robots right the self-replicating ones
that expand exponentially which sure do
the trick of course that's gonna be a
lot harder now you've killed all the
nerds isn't it our most trusted officers
were each given a planet to weaken by
themselves over the course of 20 [ __ ]
years even on his own i'm sure omniman
could have conquered earth in six months
max what's he been doing thinking maybe
understand if he spent that time
convincing earth's governments that
viltor might rule was in their best
interests but it never even comes up 20
years of superheroing and father
figuring and for what we need to get
earth ready to join the viltrum empire
but why to paraphrase a certain captain
of the enterprise what does god need
with a human biltramite dna is so pure
you're nearly full-blooded is nearly
full-blooded really going to be enough
for a species that thanos half of its
actually full-blooded population for
being too weak but we can help them we
can stop wars eliminate hunger omniman's
burden i do love your mother
but
she's more like a
a pet to me shows dropped enough hints
at nolan and debbie doing the horizontal
mambo the biggest being mark then i'm
now hoping nolan just never learned the
proper use of the word pet what do you
think is gonna happen
then i'm gonna go enslave my friends for
a bunch of aliens i've never met built
for my kids being able to give this much
side eye without ever turning your head
i truly hope mark lives up to his name
he's going to say it isn't he to face
his father and survive want to build up
on this one huh he'll need to be
wait what what is this okay that's just
me having a bit of fun
i mean if you're gonna be that
predictable you really leave me no
choice but to make my own fun everyone
in this group apparently attended
classes at the chicago campus of the
rickon stark school of running away from
things calculating the relative weights
of abraham lincoln's head and asteroid
flying through space in this falling
building is an amount of math that is
very much above my pay grade that being
said this show is doing an insufficient
job of helping us understand how heavy
anything is for these powered
individuals so even though this building
may actually be heavy for invincible we
have no way to tell if that makes sense
or is just what the story needed at the
moment ironically we missed this in a
previous episode but as one of our great
communicators once said fool me once
shame on
shame on you fool me a full man can't
get fooled again so the sin as always is
a nihilist that was your fault your
stubbornness against the inevitable
killed those people confusing
stubbornness with newton's laws of
motion
how can you say those things i suppose
we're meant to believe cecil's getting
this footage from the little flying ball
things they introduced earlier so here's
a sin for convenient footage provided by
convenient tech which nolan is
conveniently not destroying maybe this
time you'll learn we can't show much
more of the scene so instead enjoy these
royalty-free pictures of puppies while i
remove a sin for the sheer brutality of
this train sequence this is exactly the
sort of an actual super villain would
pull to demonstrate to mark how fragile
humanity is and how they're powerless to
resist vulture my supremacy
no puppies i see you almost die to
protect them maybe you were a viltromite
when you came to earth but you've
changed saying this to your father after
he just used your face is a weapon of
mass destruction i don't know if this is
a filter might quark but i feel like
mark's suit shouldn't be moving
independently of the blood that's
covering it omniman is like breaking the
sound barrier right now or some so again
where is this footage coming from if
cecil brought joseph kaczynski into
direct we have a right to know
omniman is a dick to this boat twice i
can always start again
make another kid nothing in the season
has really answered the question of why
nolan had a kid in the first place or
why he did such a bad job of
indoctrinating mark into his whole
master species belief system i mean not
that i wanted that but we all know you
have to start such things pretty early
right
if i have to watch this game i'd have a
better view from above believing the
only thing preventing baseball from
being watchable is altitude this is a
waste of everyone's time there's so much
more i could be doing right now well
yeah but it comes with my amazon prime
subscription which is worth it for the
two day shipping alone and this show is
by no means the worst oh we're still on
baseball aren't we when he feels joy we
feel joy we interrupt this flashback
which interrupted a truly epic superhero
ass beating to bring you debbie
explaining the unshakeable bond between
parent and child and as sweet as that is
it ends up making this scene entirely
safe mark plays stickball really well
and everyone cheers and that is a lie
who cheers for someone else's kid in
fact they're only five other people here
in the bleachers and if the teams are
even the four blue shirted kids here i
mean there should be at least eight kids
total now unless none of the blue
shirted kids have parents that love them
enough to put up with baseball why is
everyone cheering for team red mark's
blood not being invincible i can't begin
to explain the devastation all the
important people just so happen to be
tuned into the same news position
channel at this exact time joe continues
to give us updates on the whereabouts
and goings on of the mahler twins win at
this point we don't care and if we're
honest did we ever this hathem book the
guardians of the globe and adam eve
are on the scene okay the guardians mean
well but rescue operations like this are
incredibly complicated i doubt duplicate
has a clue how to safely remove this
child from these iron bars and don't
even get me started on rexplode
literally blowing up rubble to find
survivors to keep you and mark safe
nolan grayson officially died when the
house across the street exploded sure
won't look at all suspicious that nolan
grayson who looks identical to omniman
died on the same day that omniman went
on a rampage and also disappeared at
least clark kent had [ __ ] glasses in
a different hairstyle and don't be
alarmed if you see yourself in mark on
the news
we sent proxies to the funeral they've
already had the [ __ ] funeral without
even telling debbie nolan is dead and
the media were there holy [ __ ] won't
debbie's friends and family think it a
bit odd that they weren't invited no one
was doing everything under my nose and i
never saw it
i wouldn't be able to live with myself
if i didn't make things as right as it
can be oh my that wasn't a jab right
into debbie's heart this devious prick
just angered me so much that i was
compelled to give this a sin but then i
realized i felt that way because his
character was written and performed so
well that he made me feel a feeling
which compelled me to remove a sin but
then i realized that making me feel
anything against my own will is an
automatic ads oh
also saying nolan was doing everything
under my nose would be overselling in a
bit i mean he did kill the guardians of
the globe but aside from that all we
have evidence of him doing is raising a
family writing travel books and saving
the world occasionally i said stop
just a reminder that monster girl can
only do this a certain amount of times
before she benjamin buttons herself into
oblivion was posing for the discount
avengers glory shot really worth that we
get it they're a team now moody montage
of life returning to normal set against
an equally moody indie song cliche the
animators who obviously took advantage
of a sale at the generic green backpack
store the angle on the shot is weird and
makes it look like debbie is sleeping
standing up against the wall but the
real issue is that with all the [ __ ]
technology at his disposal cecil still
couldn't get her a bed wait a minute you
know he's invincible oh man you know too
oh thank god i thought i blew it you did
but fortunately for everyone involved
these slip-ups tend to only happen when
both parties are already aware of the
secret and the plot just needs them to
both get on the same page as quickly as
possible you've been drifting and out
for almost two weeks but my guys got you
patched up good taking credit for
someone else's power of invincibility
invincibut the water america drinks so
conveniently from their taps is laced
with a chemical that inhibits the
ability to see certain frequencies of
light using your show to invent insane
conspiracy theories is all fun and games
until someone attempts to cure
themselves with magic rocks invest their
life savings in a psychic stock broker
rewards an oscar army of the dead
there's enough actual madness in the
world without having my animated shows
add to it thank you you and everyone
else in america do not have the ability
to see the things in this room
you'd be surprised how often we use this
i swear the show is making this
description just vague enough to make me
look like a dick for questioning it but
the show forgets that i have zero issues
looking like a dick so here we go let's
assume that the chemical in question has
been invented without a single
whistleblower coming forward about this
tampering with the water table how does
this work in the real world okay this
room is flooded with that light but how
do you use it outside of this room
without it looking like a sudden white
void of nothingness has suddenly
appeared we monitored your father until
he left our solar system
he didn't change trajectory so he's
going somewhere pretty damn far away nor
he waited until he knew he was out of
range and then changed direction
basically cecil you don't have a [ __ ]
clue so don't you stand there and expect
me to take your retina altering
dihydrogen monoxide quietly guess who's
finally getting his powers previously on
invincible again you know how many man
is mine said your dad was killed when a
gas line blew up across the street
not that hard to figure it out from
there right what did i just say oh man
it's so good to see you're all right i
mean after everything on the tv about
you and omni william [ __ ] this up again
and again it doesn't matter because the
person who he thinks doesn't know the
secret and really shouldn't know the
secret knows the secret someone's flying
towards earth from deep space we're
still trying to figure out who it is but
writers thinking we would fall for this
omni man returning to earth fake out
with less than 10 minutes left in the
episode you know about mark and omniman
now so you might as well know about me
why what kind of logic is that this is
like cecil saying welp you know about
the invisa potions we've all been
pumping into your faucets so you may as
well know about the aliens that killed
kennedy or the ai from the future that
now runs the planet after manipulating
the internet into creating the snyder
cut just as a demonstration of its power
from the sounds of it i'm the one who
should be apologizing if i'd checked my
orders properly i would have seen that
earth was flagged for vulture might take
over yes but that would have been mighty
inconvenient for a series that depends
on keeping its main character in the
dark until the finale much better to
make you exactly as incompetent as the
plot requires until it doesn't anymore
can't imagine what you're going through
literally never even met my father
[Laughter]
i'm sitting the season for not having
more seth rogen i mean alan the alien
what's the plan in the meantime how do
you say next season on invincible
without saying next season on invincible
you'll think you've been [ __ ] by a
train
have you even smoking any pot today
how high are you thumbs up their asses
thumbs up their asses do you have any
idea how much i make a year i mean even
if i told you you wouldn't believe it
hey buzz you're flying this isn't blind
this is falling with style
look what they need to mimic a fraction
of our power danger zone
it was at this moment that he knew
he [ __ ] up i exist
only to protect krypton that is the sole
purpose
for which i was born
oh my
that is a no-no did you see that did you
see oh that was amazing
i've seen better swings on a playground
wait a minute where are we you are no
longer part of the system
you are above the system
over it
beyond it we're them
where they
we are the men in black